first on cbs mornings kelsey ballerini
and kane brown are with us from
nashville good morning hi kelsey it's kb
and kb
exactly wait so
yeah it is but wait we got to ask you
how are you feeling how are you doing
kelsey
oh thanks for asking i you know what i'm
feeling much better um i'm more bummed
than anything luckily um
physically feeling okay at this point um
just a bit of a broken heart that's all
um i know i get it kelsey i'll bet you
had your dress all picked out too i bet
you had your outfit ready you were ready
to go i was so looking forward to seeing
you on the stage tonight but we're glad
you're okay
thank you gail don't you worry i still
have five outfit changes and i'm wearing
them all oh okay okay
fair enough cool all right and my man
came
yeah this is so cool you've hosted uh
past two cmt awards but you've always
had to prepare um what's it like getting
a phone call though at the very last
minute it's like kane are you busy can
you join us can you host i know kanan
when did you get the call kane that you
were going to be on the stage tonight
because i think wow uh the day before
yesterday i was in pennsylvania wow
i had to rush back and then uh pulled up
and rehearsed
yesterday
so it was cool
and i'm excited it's very interesting
how all we got it set up with kelsey and
um
you know i'm just so excited to get to
do it again i was honestly kind of boned
when i found out that you only do it two
years in a row and then they pass it on
to somebody else so i'm glad i get to to
come back and do it yeah you know you
might also have to prepare an accepted
acceptance speech you're the most
nominated artist and you're up for best
video of the year one of the top
categories uh what does that mean to you
what do all your nominations mean to you
mail video of the year cmt performance
of the year
um i'm just really excited because this
is the one that you know fans
get to participate in
um
regardless i'm excited that i'm up with
some some amazing artists
and friends of mine um so yeah i'm just
excited for the fans and and they get to
see what happens and i'm excited for to
get together like once
i like one mississippi for video of the
year i'll take that one oh i know i i
like anything kane brown does i'll just
say that kelsey you're nominated for
three big awards tonight
so what makes this award show different
in addition to the fans i always say
this the country music people and the
country fans i think are some of the
best it's it's
you guys are just totally different from
other artists in my opinion so what
makes this this show so special to you
well i i think kind of what kane said
it's it's country music puts the
storytelling and the fans at the front
always that's what makes it special i
think and so this show honors what the
fans want to hear and it honors the
videos that tell the story of the song
and so to me it really is kind of the
full picture of what country music's
about and what country music's about
right now it's really giving the
snapshot of what it sounds like what it
looks like what it feels like this year
and um i think that's really special
there are a lot of awesome performances
kelsey that we're looking forward to but
i'm also looking very much forward to
winona and naomi judd getting back
together on the stage for the first time
in a really long time how excited are
you about that
the first time in 20 years i mean i
think if nothing else just tune in for
that because that that doesn't happen a
lot obviously and have that moment on
the show is just it's wild i think
everyone's just
ready for it
yeah right you know what else we're
ready for kane brown your new music
when's it coming i hear your wife
approves she thinks it's one of your
best when's it coming because we cannot
wait and by we i mean me
all of us
uh i don't know the exact date but the
album's finished um okay so
wait for it i will say though my wife's
on there so we got a song out uh it's
gonna come out i'm excited about it
so kelsey will we where will you be
doing the show tonight will you be at
home are you in a total separate
location how is that going to work
so i thought i was gonna wear all the
hats just in general posting performing
and being nominated now i'm hosting
performing and being nominated and i'm
my own hair and makeup my own camera
crew my own lighting um yeah welcome to
our world in the early days of covington
oh my god so yeah cmt dropped off a rig
um i i'm performing in my backyard they
they brought a piece of the pink carpet
to my driveway um love it yeah so it's
it's very sweet of them to still include
me but yeah if anything goes wrong it's
definitely my fault
oh no it'll be great it'll be great
you're going to crush it kelsey
ballerini chelsea kane and anthony
mackey tonight it'll be great yeah thank
you guys we're looking forward to it the
cmt awards will air tonight at 8 7
central right here on cbs and also
stream on paramount plus